i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks using my link below
well my friends joe biden is doing it
joe biden will be cancelling up to
twenty thousand dollars in student loan
debt for those making under a hundred
and twenty five thousand dollars it'll
be ten thousand dollars for most folks
but there's a pell grant element to it
which could raise that to twenty
thousand dollars we're going to look at
the details and i have to tell you
producer pat was completely correct in
his prediction producer pat has been
predicting on the award-winning bonus
show
that
at a time
advantageous to democrats for the
midterm elections
joe biden would do some larger student
loan forgiveness than he has done so far
now remember that joe biden has already
done even before this
more student loan forgiveness than any
other president and we've covered that
before and pat said it's going to be
close-ish to the november midterms joe
biden's going to do something and i just
didn't think he was and here we are
producer pat completely correct new york
times reporting biden to cancel 10 000
in student debt
low income students are eligible for
more
uh the plan would be
ten thousand dollars in cancellation for
those earning under a hundred and twenty
five thousand dollars a year
and twenty thousand dollars for those
who received pell grants for low income
families now the debt forgiveness is
less than what some democrats have been
pushing for and we will talk about that
uh biden also announced that a pandemic
era pause on student loan payments
uh which has been in effect since march
of 2020 will expire at the end of the
year
there is not yet an application process
this has been a big question okay so how
do how do we get
the forgiveness if we qualify
what's the process
that process has not yet been made
specific
um a couple of other important notes
here
students who receive pell grants will be
able to get up to 20 000 in forgiveness
about sixty percent of borrowers have
pell grants and the majority come from
families earning under thirty thousand
dollars a year the education department
estimates 27 million borrowers will
qualify for up to twenty thousand in
relief then you've got millions more who
will be able to get the 10 000
and uh there are a number of other
repayment uh modifications that are
being made as well so let's go through
some of the different
reactions to this and then we're going
to delve further into it so one reaction
is this is not enough 10 000 is not
enough 20 000 is not enough fine
fine but this is already
overwhelmingly more than any other
president has done by far so as i've
said before
i tend to evaluate presidents based on
what they do
generally speaking
and also for things they promised to do
but don't do i think both are fair game
just saying well this president's bad
because he didn't do these 10 things
that he never promised to do
that seems to be a way to end up
with relatively meaningless evaluations
of presidents so
when you look at what joe biden has done
he has by far for given more student
that than any other president um
counterpoint joe biden's only doing this
to help democrats in november well i
mean listen everything politicians do to
some degree is to help themselves is it
also good for people and the answer is
this is very good for people and there
are also some new rules for income-based
repayment plans which are arguably as
big of a deal as the forgiveness
repayment will be capped at five percent
of discretionary income rather than ten
that's a big source of relief your
payments are zero
if you are below 225 percent of the
federal poverty line uh due to an
increase in the non-discretionary
fraction of income
unpaid interest is waived as long as
you're making monthly payments even if
the payments uh are zero based on those
earlier guidelines that i mentioned and
that's really a game changer
many people
are much more able to pay off a debt
if they're not accumulating and accruing
more and more and more interest through
the payment process
and that's a really big deal and then
forgiveness after 10 years on loans
under 12 000
rather than only 20 thousand dollars
uh which is uh another interesting
provision so there is a significant
amount of relief here in addition to the
forgiveness component for lower and
middle income borrowers and that's a
really really big deal now one question
is what does this do in terms of
democrat chances
going into the november midterms as we
have talked about before
right now in the house of
representatives i'm sorry in the senate
the odds for democrats have crept up
from a 52 shot at holding the senate to
55 high 50s
60 and now 64
right now the 538 estimate the forecast
is that democrats have a 64 chance of
retaining control of the senate we will
see whether that number increases on the
basis of this announcement from joe
biden in terms of the house of
representatives well republicans are
still favored to hold but by a smaller
uh
margin
than at any previous point during this
cycle right now republicans are down to
a 78 percent chance of taking the house
of representatives democrats at 22 still
the most likely outcome is democrats
keep the senate but lose the house but
the house numbers are looking it's hard
to call them good for democrats but they
are looking the least bad that they have
looked since we've started following
this election cycle so this is another
major major accomplishment by joe biden
later on in the show i am going to now
compare and contrast
the 180 that has taken place for the
biden administration which is which is
truly remarkable i mean if you look at
the biden administration two months ago
and now
it is truly stunning the change that we
have seen we're going to talk about that
and we're going to contrast that with
what's going on on the republican side
including a growing civil war wherein
former president donald trump is calling
for the removal of mitch mcconnell as
the senate minority leader it could not
be a greater contrast than what we are
seeing that'll come up a little bit
later i want to address now
one of the most common arguments that
the right is making against the student
loan debt forgiveness
this is unfair
to people who already paid off their
student loans or don't have student
loans
this is the argument that many
right-wingers are now making well
whatever you can say about the merits of
helping people who currently have
student loan debt it's very unfair to
those who don't have student loan debt
or to those who worked hard to pay off
their student loan debt already joe
biden yesterday during a press
conference that he gave a press took
questions at the end of a statement i
guess is a better way to say it
uh was asked about this
what about the people who paid off their
student
loans or chose not to take out loans
is it fair to people who in fact
do not own multi-billion dollar
businesses they've seen why these guys
give them all the taxes is that fair
what do you think
what about people who paid their loans
so struggle to pay their loans and now
others don't have to all right so that's
peter ducey there at the end yelling out
a question so let's talk about that i
paid off my student loans i had student
loans i could have waited
um i don't care if joe biden forgives
everybody else's loans first of all this
is good for the economy it's demand side
stimulus when people aren't paying
interest
to big mega lenders
that money they then have to put into
their local economy small businesses
maybe they can get a david pakman show
membership now because they don't have
to funnel that money
into these mega financial corporations
so it's good for the economy and i like
things that are good for the economy so
could i have waited and taken a chance
that someday
maybe joe biden would or someone would
pay off some forgive some student loans
and maybe i would be under the income
limit but maybe i would sure i could
have done that but i didn't and it's
it's just not a problem for me but
here's the other thing the people that
already paid off their student loans yes
they they don't get the forgiveness
but they freed up money for other things
much sooner so i get it
you you went through the struggle of
paying off your student loans three
years ago and now you're missing out on
10k possibly 20k
but three years ago you were able to
redirect the money that had and would
have been going to your student loans if
you're relatively financially competent
to savings to building an emergency fund
to starting a retirement account to
contributing to low-cost index funds or
whatever so it's not like you just lost
because you paid off your loans and now
there's forgiveness
you have freed up that money to do other
things with during the intervening time
to improve your financial position so
it's a very silly argument now you can
take this idea
and apply it to almost anything i mean
listen it would be unfair if republicans
were to now cut taxes
because look at all these people who for
all these years paid a higher tax rate
well that that doesn't really make sense
they never make that argument
i n me i'm talking now is me david i
didn't get a federal tax credit for my
electric vehicle but now they're putting
in new tax credits for electric vehicles
that's not fair to me well yep it's okay
life's not always necessarily fair but i
got my vehicle earlier rather than
burning gas for the last three years
waiting for the credit
i've had an electric vehicle and i've
reduced my fueling expense i mean come
on yeah i saw on twitter
every black person should still have to
be a slave because it's not fair to the
former slaves i mean it's an absurd
thing right
we're expanding it into absurd arguments
but it's more or less the principle i
saw on reddit
would it be unfair to the people that
the trolley has already killed to divert
it now to prevent it from killing more
people
uh that's a trolley problem one so those
are all terrible criticisms now here is
a good criticism and again it's a
criticism but we're talking about
different things here is a fair
assessment
of what the forgiveness does not do
i guess what i find
annoying about it is that it doesn't
address the higher education cartel and
it basically is infusing money into a
higher education system that is
basically just corrupt at this point you
look at how much tuition has just
skyrocketed over the last 20 30 years i
mean my college tuition i it was it's
three times today what it was 20 years
ago and that's just absurd and it
doesn't do any that's not accessible for
the majority of americans so that's
absolutely true that's msnbc analyst
elise jordan and she correctly points
out this doesn't address
the skyrocketing cost of college it
doesn't do that and that's why joe biden
and others have said well we should have
free community college start putting in
place
lower cost competition to the higher
education cartel to put some downward
pressure on prices that's absolutely
accurate this doesn't do that this is
debt relief it's not an institutional
reform they're both related to education
but they are independent issues and what
should be done next is we need to figure
out how to deal with the pricing issue
absolutely this doesn't fix that
but that doesn't mean the forgiveness is
a bad idea so some real brain rot
happening on the right uh right wingers
uh on the brains of right wingers in the
united states as a result of this i
think part of what's going on is they
realize this is very bad for them in
november and after the break we're going
to talk about that i want to remind you
that next wednesday
6 p.m eastern time we are going to be
doing our first in a really long time
members only town hall we've done
monthly town halls open to everybody and
we're going to continue doing those this
wednesday we're doing a member only town
hall which if anybody it will be
streamed live anybody who wants to watch
it is welcome to
but only join pacman.com members
will be welcome to call in and chat with
me okay so sign up at joinpacman.com
that town hall coming up wednesday
august 31st at 6 p.m eastern 3 p.m
pacific it's gonna be a good one
i've talked on the show before about how
we have dealt with hacking and it's a
terrible feeling you have to act quickly
the problem can get worse fast if you
don't and i now protect myself with aura
aura monitors my email addresses
passwords bank accounts credit cards all
of that stuff and sends me alerts if
anything has been compromised it's
identity theft protection and fraud
monitoring all wrapped together aura
continuously monitors the dark web
looking for your private info you get an
alert as soon as something is discovered
aura also does things like alert you if
there are suspicious credit inquiries if
someone opens or tries to open an
account in your name i've gotten useful
alerts from my aura app and i was able
to act on them quickly if you don't have
a tool like aura i highly recommend it
and when you go to aura.com
pacman you will get aura free for 14
days which you can use to do things like
see if your passwords have been leaked
the link is down below
so predictably republicans right-wing
media extremists on the right
authoritarians uh the usual suspects are
furious about the student loan debt
forgiveness that joe biden is doing now
this is another great accomplishment for
joe biden and in the next story i'm
actually going to go through the
incredible two-month 180
arguably one of the the greatest
turnarounds in a presidency
certainly that i've covered and i would
argue in decades in the united states
but before we get to that
one of the real reasons that republicans
are melting down and panicking over joe
biden student loan debt forgiveness that
was announced yesterday
is that on some level they realize
43 million people
directly benefit
and then their families their spouses
their parents who might be helping with
the payment whoever the children
everybody benefits indirectly as well
and republicans realize that this could
be really bad for them in the november
midterms but they have nothing else to
do
than to make outrageous claims about why
this is bad well this is unfair to
people who have paid their student loans
we talked about that in the last segment
this is a handout this teaches people
they don't have to be financially
responsible or whatever else the case
may be
and part of what's happening is they
know this is very bad for them let's
look at a couple of examples of this
here's fox news propagandist tucker
carlson whose lawyers uh have argued in
court that he's not really doing news
he's doing entertainment and nothing he
says should really be taken seriously
that's a legal defense to tucker
carlson's program um tucker carlson says
that the student debt relief is a form
of reparations being paid to
drug-addicted robots who have no job
prospects wow
so when joe biden announced day that he
plans to cancel some of that debt the
obvious response would be to celebrate
the announcement but we didn't right
away oh instead we paused to learn the
details about what he was proposing
that's a habit we've picked up from
watching people like joe biden in action
over the past several years it's always
worth reading the fine print these are
the very same people after all who
decided it was a good idea somehow to
defund the police
they're the ones okay now remember
they haven't defunded the police
and as far as joe biden's concerned
he has nothing to do with police funding
i mean just it's just neither here nor
there it's a complete non-sequitur you
forced the entire american population to
take an experimental coveted vaccine
even when it became obvious that it
didn't work
these are the people who said okay and
again there's so much to that
the initial vaccine against the initial
variant was extremely effective at
preventing infection over time its
ability to prevent infection diminish
but its
ability to prevent
serious covid death and hospitalization
was still good i mean all these one-line
lies require some time to unpack but
really this is about the student loan
debt forgiveness crack pipes to crack
addicts the ones who think 16 year olds
should vote in presidential elections
the ones who screamed at you about how
ukraine's borders are sacrosanct but
yours are racist
etc etc etc these are people in other
words with a long and public track
record of very bad ideas extraordinarily
bad ideas
ideas so stupid you couldn't make them
up
so the question is is this idea
different we want it to be
but unfortunately it's not and here's
how you know it's not
colleges aren't refunding any of the
loan money
you are
you are but wait you say i didn't
defraud anyone
i didn't claim that a degree in
post-colonial liberation studies from
wesleyan would be worth anything
i didn't take 80 grand a year for
middle-class families in order to turn
their children into xanax addicted
robots with no job prospects
listen
these are just xanax addicted robots
with no job prospects they don't deserve
the student loan forgiveness now there's
so many different ways to respond to
this
and as we've talked about earlier
it's good for the economy
for money to be going back into real
businesses
rather than just interest on student
loans paid to mega financial
corporations which people like tucker
carlson often criticize
but there's a bigger picture here which
is tucker correctly points out we have a
broken higher education system the the
other day um i was calculating what was
it we i was calculating based on how
much uh based on how much my my
girlfriend's alma mater's
tuition went up from when she graduated
to now we were calculating that when our
daughter would be 18
it would be 203 000 a year if just it
kept growing at the same rate like
obviously something has to break it's a
completely broken system tucker's
correctly identifying that
um and you know what i have even said
before
there should be some consideration
based on your major
uh whether the cost of the education is
is worthwhile right i mean when i think
about any expense i think about what's
the value and if you're going into a
field where you are unlikely to really
make money then it's perfectly fair to
consider whether the cost of the
education makes sense there's a whole
bunch of things that go into that but
again this idea of the recipients aren't
deserving is just an it's the same way
they talk about any welfare program and
it's a it's a very broken and disturbing
way to talk about it now a couple other
examples of this here is uh dan bongino
talking to jesse waters on fox news he
says that the student loan debt
forgiveness is evidence of the collapse
of america still trying to get over this
whole thing because listen jesse if you
were um doing a tutorial on what the
collapse of great empires look like yeah
just pick up your phone start the video
camera because this is exactly what it
looks like and just leave it running
this is the movie this is the
autobiography of the autobiography of
the american empire collapsing before
our very eyes yep 10k
of student loan forgiveness for those
making under 125 000
and 20k
for pell grant recipients
that's the end of american civilization
now of course the counterpoints are
just about every country in western and
northern europe where they're
flourishing
they're a good business environments
people have health care the health care
is good education is good uh quality of
life is good life expectancy is good and
in many cases they have college
education paid through taxation now
here government money for for the
forgiveness means it's taxpayer money
that's absolutely true
and it's really no different than the
taxpayer money directly paying for the
education in this case it didn't
directly pay for it now it's going to be
part of the forgiveness
it's not the indication of a collapsing
empire many of the best countries in the
world to live in have education paid for
through taxation now one more bongino
clip here he is
um
it's more kind of like lazy like the
these people everybody's lazy according
to bungino what's happening here really
has me a little annoyed because there's
this thing an income repayment program
you know what it's called
it's called the freaking job and here's
how this works a job there's this thing
let me just do a demo for you all at
home okay there's this thing you have
it's called the ass right here the ass
okay and when the ass gets up out of the
seat and goes to work and you remove the
ass from the seat you get this thing
it's a four-letter word called a job
some of you know joe biden will get the
joke
you get the job and then you pay back
the loan okay so first of all
right-wingers think that that's like a
thinker they see they believe bungino is
a thinker now
aside from the lazy narrative just being
it's a lazy narrative quite frankly it's
lazy to just do the lazy narrative
a lot of the people i don't know how old
he is but a lot of the people who say
just work and pay for school that's all
when they were in school
relative to income
college was exponentially cheaper it was
orders of magnitude cheaper the
relationship fact tom hartman has talked
about on his program how his wife louise
if i recall correctly basically waitress
to pay for college the idea now
that you could work like in food service
to pay for college
is absurd because the relationship
between the cost of college and the
minimum wage and the median wage has
gotten completely out of whack so these
people don't know what they're talking
about but they're certainly trying to
make you think that they do all right
the joe biden presidency has done a
complete 180. it is stunning the degree
to which the biden presidency is turned
around think back to two and a half or
so months ago
no major no major recent accomplishments
for joe biden
approval rating in trump's favorite
place in the toilet the third element of
the bathroom
not looking good for november
the re-election of joe biden a seeming
impossibility based on the direction
things were going
but then we started to put together a
bunch of different things that took
place and from further back we had of
course uh getting out of afghanistan
which was an absolutely fantastic
decision did it go perfectly no it went
about as well as it would if trump had
done it but we're out of afghanistan we
now have joe biden's student loan
forgiveness package which is a major
deal and i believe will absolutely help
democrats in november
we had an incredible july jobs report
about a quarter million jobs were
expected
more than half a million jobs were
actually created wages are up
inflation is down
gas prices have been steadily coming
down and significantly we've had the
pact act signed the inflation reduction
act has been signed we've got the older
infrastructure bill which biden did
and then on the other side look at
what's happening for the right wing the
revelations from the january 6th
committee disastrous disastrous for
trump and people around him
completely bonkers maga nominees we'll
talk about laura loomer after the break
just cartoonish nuts running herschel
walker doug mastriano all these people
roe v wade overturned something the
right has wanted for so long absolutely
horrifying
uh trump busted with documents at his
house and now we learned the number of
documents is in the hundreds and it's
all completely crazy and meanwhile the
republican civil war is growing wherein
donald trump is now calling for the
removal and replacement of mitch
mcconnell as the republican leader in
the senate currently the senate minority
leader probably will remain in the
minority after the november midterms
what an incredible turnaround for joe
biden and what an incredible contrast to
what's going on on the republican side
no policy ideas they haven't had policy
ideas for years remember the health care
plan that was weeks from coming out in
the summer of 2020 and then we never got
the healthcare plans because there is no
healthcare plan no policy just get in
the way of democrats that's it
uh the civil war
the absolutely brazen nature with which
they just lie in line lying tell the
same lies over and over again including
about the 2020 election there could be
no greater contrast right now but the
contrast alone wouldn't be that notable
the two month turnaround of the biden
presidency has been stunning
now
will it make a difference in november
because it looks like democrats probably
will keep the senate but lose the house
can something different happen in the
house if democrats were able to keep the
house and senate in november
it would be historic
given what normally happens in midterms
after a new party takes the white house
incredible let me know your thoughts and
all the clips we played in these
segments will be on our instagram if you
want to check them out search instagram
for david pakman show and also find me
on instagram at david.pacman check out
some of my pictures from the last week
in canada and i will tell some stories
on the bonus show about that as well
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
so we have to have a conversation about
something not so good that's happening
on the i guess i would call it the
online left media
in the online left media world which is
a level of pettiness
that at this point should concern every
single one of us that actually wants to
get some things done and make some
progress and maybe not see democrats
completely crushed in the november
midterm elections
uh and what i'm talking about is
a very toxic subculture that's taking
place among many in the audience of
shows like mine
uh in which there is just a completely
counterproductive self-destructive
argumentation happening constantly about
which show is better
who's a shill
this show's bad that shows bad pacman's
terrible this that the other thing and
the reason that i sort of came across
this is a couple people sent me over the
not over the weekend over the last few
days i was getting back from my trip
um
some links to some of subreddit
discussions and discord discussions
where my name comes up in the context of
am i one of the good guys or am i one of
the bad guys why am i terrible and you
can find lots of reasons why i'm
terrible including i'm terrible because
my uh youtube titles are uh click bait
or because i'm not doing enough deep
foreign policy analysis
or because you know i have a bonus show
oh the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad or whatever and
this stuff is all happening supposedly
among people on the left who share like
95
of the same goals
so let's just sort of like start at the
middle and work our way out but right so
so like let's take the criticism
my show is bad
because i do this type of show and not
that type of show i don't do deep
foreign policy analysis listen
um every show has a different niche and
a different goal
the point of this show is to be
a popularizer of being informed
of thinking about how political choices
impact the world we live in
to be a a show that inspires people to
actually at minimum vote if not do more
which nearly half the country doesn't do
and to warn people about the horrifying
reality of the scourge
that is right-wing extremism and
reactionary politics and
authoritarianism and to make sure
everybody remembers this is not a both
side situation in the united states we
really have one side that is completely
out of their mind and another side
that's just not quite left enough for me
and those are two very different things
we talk to interesting smart people from
different fields to expose people in the
audience to the fact that all these
different fields exist and if one of
them piques your interest then you can
do deep dives into that find books five
find podcasts to deep dive into any
particular topic that interests you
create a like-minded a community of
like-minded people to come together
through the show itself and our discord
and our subreddit and all these
different things
and then you can say well i really care
about education so in addition to
listening to the pacman podcast i'll
listen to podcasts about education for
example or i care about climate change
so i'll add some climate youtubers
uh science climatologist youtubers to my
subscriptions or whatever
and uh
that is really the point of this
particular show so yes this is not a
show that is exclusively
long-form foreign policy analysis
that doesn't mean that this show is any
better or any worse than a different
show now yes different shows of
different levels of production quality
different shows of different levels of
you you know experience for the host or
whatever the case may be
but this sniping thing that i see so
many people in my audience and in other
audiences engage in about oh sam cedar's
bad because of his view on this one
issue or tyt is good better than pac-man
because of this or pac-man shows
this is extraordinarily petty and
self-destructive and the right doesn't
do this
the right does a lot of horrible things
which we criticize but the right just
looks at
is are these people basically helping
our movement or are they basically
hurting our movement
is this someone who we mostly agree with
and that's kind of the starting point
and unfortunately i continue to worry
that this level of pettiness and sniping
on the left is going to be very very bad
for the movement apply the analogy to
books right i don't read political
memoirs i didn't read you know uh
obama's book
i didn't read the kushner book i didn't
read hillary's book i did i just have
other things i prefer to read
it doesn't mean that as a genre the
political memoir is bad i mean some are
bad some are poorly written it's a niche
and there's a need for it and that's
great but it would be weird for me to
say well i think narrative non-fiction
is better than political memoirs how do
you even compare those things and so
let's all take a step back
let's understand
who is generally advocating for the
right things the things that we believe
in the things that will improve the
country and the world in which we which
we live
and let's not inflict
this kind of circular firing squad of
self-inflicted damage it's just very bad
and pettiness is really the best way
that i can describe it let me know what
you think
i have to tell you
i don't normally take great pleasure in
this type of thing
but i took great pleasure in lunatic
republican laura loomer sobbing while
claiming that the election was stolen
from her
by a republican we're going to look at
the video in a moment it is really
something else if you're not familiar
with laura loomer
laura loomer was a far right
congressional candidate she was running
first and foremost in florida in a
primary against daniel webster okay
she ran a primary against daniel webster
and she lost the primary
this is florida's 11th congressional
district laura loomer 29 years old
complete and total extremist
and um she lost and she just she just
lost there's there's really nothing else
to it
um
this is a republican stronghold district
the republican party has received at
least 65 percent of the vote in the last
three elections in 2020
loomer won a primary in florida's 21st
district but was then crushed in what is
an unfavorable district if she had won
this week she probably would have won
the general because now she was running
in a very conservative district but
daniel webster won
and there's this incredible video where
she is sobbing and saying fraud cost her
the win and i have to tell you that to
some degree i find this absolutely
hilarious
we are losing our country because of big
tech election interference and i am
pleading with the republican party to
please start taking this issue seriously
please because the american people
deserve representation and that's
that's why i ran for congress in 2020
it's why i ran for congress in 2022 and
it's why i'm going to keep fighting for
all of you
yeah
so she's asking republicans to stop the
voter fraud in a republican primary in a
red district completely run by
republicans so i guess it's really not
democrats that are doing the voter fraud
and of course if you actually confront
them with that and you say wait you guys
spent the second half of 2020
arguing that it's democratic voter fraud
that's going to result in the theft of
an election and it was the democratic
machine that stole it from trump and
gave it to biden
but now they lose a republican primary
and they use the exact same series of
talking points so it's democrats and
republicans and then they'll say yeah
it's the rhino republicans the the rhino
republicans which means republican in
name only they're not really republicans
they are just as bad with the voter
fraud so but in 2020 a lot of those
rhinos won
but you didn't say there was voter fraud
then no well in 2020 it was just the
democrats but then now it's the
republicans and the primaries
this is absurd and it is a great thing
that laura loomer lost laura loomer has
promoted mass shooting conspiracies like
for example claiming parkland was staged
the vegas shooter was isis she claimed a
right winger who was arrested for having
illegal weapons was actually antifa she
described herself as a pro-white
nationalist so i think you get it this
is an absolutely completely and totally
horrible person and then she put out a
statement on some platform saying she
doesn't concede and it's crazy she wrote
i do not concede
and i encourage all of my supporters and
all of my voters to not support daniel
webster and the corrupt establishment
rnc
and the big tech voter fraud machine
that is propping his feeble body up and
depriving my constituents of the
representation they deserve a need i'm
calling for daniel webster to resign
because everyone knows he is beyond
unfit to serve um you know i think
that's a message i can actually get
behind
if laura loomer is saying in november in
the 11th district don't go out and vote
for daniel webster you it's a mostly
republican district
i'm absolutely fine with them staying
home i would never advocate for people
not to vote i think
it's not a good thing to tell people
don't vote but if they want to tell
their supporters not to vote i am
absolutely all for it it's hilarious
that this is what is going on with laura
loomer and deservedly so not that daniel
webster is that much better he's not
he's no beauty right to use donald
trump's phraseology
but uh loomer would have been extremely
dangerous it is a great thing that she
lost she lost fair and square
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs
and t-shirts you can support the show
for as little as two dollars a month
check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show can democrats win in
the fall by running on maintaining and
restoring abortion rights we have an
early signal that suggests the answer at
least in some districts might be yes
this is a super interesting story
democrats just want to swind swing
district by focusing on abortion and
that should scare republicans writes
phillip elliott for time magazine
this is a very interesting situation
um
now an unexpected echo to yesterday's
column democrats may not be toast in the
house it's a long shot but there's a new
data point from tuesday evening that
makes it more plausible
sending republicans in washington into a
late night scramble how had they gotten
a new york special election so wrong
the seat representing new york's 19th
congressional district
opened in may when congressman delgado
was appointed lieutenant governor
obama twice won the hudson river valley
district before it pivoted to trump in
2016 and biden in 2020. it's a swing
district with more than 90 percent of
ballots reported democratic nominee pat
ryan was ahead with 52 of the vote
enough to send him to dc through the
balance of delgado's term
maybe everything isn't entirely terrible
for democrats maybe question uh both
parties nominated mainstream candidates
to fill delgado's seat they invested in
the race abortion rights was the um a
primary
uh topic for democrats and the economy
for republicans in an almost perfect
swing district the small turnout
election favored the democrat a county
executive from the establishment wing of
the party this comes on the heels of
kansas voters rejecting an amendment to
the kansas constitution
that would have made it easier to
further restrict access to abortion
this is very interesting because the
conventional wisdom is it's the economy
stupid if the perception is the
economy's good it's good for whoever is
in power if the perception is the
economy is bad it's good for whoever is
out of power now in a mixed uh
administration a mixed congress figuring
out well who's in can have different
interpretations but putting that aside
for a moment
typically
particularly for democrats when they run
on something like abortion or social
issues generally it's not particularly
good but we have a situation here in
this it's admittedly it's a special
election but it is like the perfect
swing district
the candidate who is a democrat running
on abortion rights
won
is this a sign
that maybe november won't be as bad for
democrats as some are predicting in the
house well it's a possibility
and we've seen it happen to some degree
in michigan
and at this point in time
with what is it about nine weeks until
the midterm elections incredibly
the economy is good and so you can walk
and chew gum at the same time the
messaging should be
look at how great the economy is
and also
these are dangerous infringements
on women's rights coming from the
republican party coming from the right
wing supreme court and we need to elect
some democrats in order to try to
reverse that and so the question becomes
was the overturning of roe v wade
potentially very bad for the republican
party we don't know the answer yet and
there are many prognosticators saying it
is bad or it's good or it doesn't matter
well ultimately these are just
predictions we won't know until we see
the results in november
the right has a playbook that they stick
to
and they are
confident that it will always work
and
the general population's views on a
number of different issues particularly
social issues but some economic issues
as well like should taxes be used on the
rich to help the general population the
country has moved to the left on
basically every single one of those
issues and in a just
and reasonable
situation
you would think that at a certain point
that
uh public belief those public
perceptions those public opinions would
be reflected in the way that the results
shake out now because of gerrymandering
and campaign finance and all these
different things voter suppression from
from republicans all the techniques that
we've talked about that they use it
hasn't happened to the degree that it
should have
maybe we will actually see that happen
in november so very good news
uh there out of that new york district
we're going to watch all districts
closely and we're going to watch the
polling in the house as we head into
november
this is really just getting sad i have
video for you today of an extremely
disheveled sounding my pillow mike
lindell
claiming that every utah vote is fake in
his latest febrile tirade
about machines and elections and all
these different things we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines okay so here is pillow
saying nobody's really voting in utah it
is all completely fabricated
you know i believe you have the ccp
the globalist the uni party
i believe it's all one just happy family
and and uh
and we showed it on on all the 50 states
you get to utah where there's no
um
one for a day election it's all mailed
in as pure crime nobody votes in utah
nobody brandon it's all just made up
so utah is a state of about 3 million
people 3.1 million people roughly live
in utah and some of them are adults and
some of them are registered to vote and
some of them actually do vote and the
idea that just it's all made up because
it's mail-in is completely and totally
absurd now i'm actually willing to go
further it's not just that no one votes
in utah
i don't even know that utah is real
i haven't been there i've never met
anyone from utah i know mitt romney
exists but do we really know that when
he left massachusetts after being
governor he really went to this place
called utah we really don't now of
course i'm kidding but in all
seriousness
we have a country
where
i don't know that i would say half
but a whole bunch of people
watch people like pillow
for entertainment purposes only right we
know
he's nuts or very confused or some
combination of the two or not with it
and we see it as a complete and total
joke and we watch to ask and to see
answered
how far
are others willing to go
in believing that anything this guy says
is based in reality right so we exist
these people are so susceptible to being
propagandized then it's just funny to
see
the other half of the country and again
it's not really half a lot of people
just don't pay attention they'd have no
clue who pillow is but you've got
another portion
that is so susceptible to being tricked
and scammed and propagandized by people
like mike pillow
um alex jones
all of these different people thank your
lucky stars every day you're not dave
pacman i know i know
and it's really an incredible contrast
and it doesn't have to be that way
they're they're i promise you we get
emails from all over the world and you
know i've been to so many different
places and engaged with the political uh
uh with political activists and systems
in a lot of countries people disagree
about policy
but you don't have a large portion of
the population to susceptible to clowns
like this guy you just don't nobody
falls for
tiny tiny portions of the population
fall for it and the vast majority of the
political discourse is sane
here's one other clip from the pillow
stuff
um
mike lindell
is reacting to it sort of seems like
he's lost steve bannon it seems like
steve bannon is not falling for all of
the machine stuff
but pillow says no no no he secretly
still believes all of it everybody knows
uh steve bannon and he always says on
his show i'm not a machine guy now you
know what i mean he said that to me
yesterday he said that to me yesterday
in the booth i'm not really a machine
guy right so then we get yeah he says
that i think so you know
deep down of course he's of course he
believes the machine's got to go of
course he does he's afraid of dominion
or smart man right
at the end of the night everybody i said
so steve are you a machine guy now he
goes i'm a machine guy yeah
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines yeah my espresso
machine is currently uh being deposed
it's crazy
um this reminds me a little bit of the
jordan peterson clip we looked at this
clip in detail because it's so
fascinating where jordan peterson said
there aren't really atheists
there are people who claim to be
atheists but deep down they really
aren't
and of course that type of statement is
completely unfalsifiable
if even what people claim to be isn't
really what they are
then you can't really actually talk
about things like atheism there's no
atheist because even the group that
describes themselves that way they're
actually religious deep down really
which religion i don't know christianity
i sort of guess
this stuff is absolutely hilarious and
there he has a following and that's
maybe the scariest thing about the
united states
uh the republican civil war is
continuing to ramp up donald trump
completely completely losing it and
asking for mitch mcconnell to be removed
immediately as the senate minority
leader and it is a tale of contrasts in
the united states in the last two months
on the one hand the biden administration
with the most stunning 180
a seemingly dying presidency two and a
half months ago
the number of biden accomplishments is
incredible we talked about it earlier
and on the other hand look at what is
happening in the american right wing
donald trump posting on his platform
truth social just hours ago
the democrats have mitch mcconnell and
his lovely wife elaine koko chow
over a barrel
he and she will never be prosecuted as
per the last paragraphs of this story as
long as he continues to give the radical
left the trillions and trillions of
dollars that they constantly demand he
was afraid to use the debt ceiling card
in order to stop the most expensive
waste of money in our country's history
to be spent on the green new deal which
will only cause one thing a depression
and then donald trump posting a
statement that by the way
elaine koko chow that's trump's uh
former secretary of transportation
now just attacking her ridiculing her
and then donald trump um uh putting out
the uh following statement where he says
much of the same things
and then adds these expenditures are
something our country can never recover
from
mitch mcconnell is not an opposition
leader he is upon for the democrats to
get whatever they want he is afraid of
them and will not do what has to be done
a new republican leader in the senate
should be picked immediately
listen
i welcome this
i welcome this republican in fighting it
can only help the odds improve for
democrats in the house and in the senate
now it's still bad in the house
democrats will almost certainly lose the
house based on the numbers as of today
if those numbers shift between now and
november we will see that and i will let
you know
but i welcome this completely and
totally wholeheartedly i hope that
donald trump continues to push this i
can't a manner imagine a better infight
before the midterms then should we
completely get rid of and push out mitch
mcconnell one of the most long-standing
and powerful republicans when there is a
fight between
listen i like adam kinzinger okay but
he's not like the most well-known
republican he's not the most powerful
republican it's great that he came out
against trump i still disagree with him
on most policy fine
we're talking about mitch mcconnell here
and the growing fight between the mega
wing
and the sort of establishment wing of
the republican party is absolutely
fantastic and one of the things that
could be particularly good about this
is that most congressional republicans
and i mean house and senate
are going to stand behind mitch
mcconnell
but they also aren't likely to publicly
oppose donald trump
and
as long as trump doesn't come out and
say you have to swear allegiance to me
you have to swear loyalty to me as long
as trump doesn't do that they can
probably get away with what is an absurd
wishy-washy position at the end of the
day which is well we stand behind mitch
mcconnell
but we also support trump if he's the
nominee or whatever
the
dream scenario will be
trump actually demands that more and
more republicans swear some kind of oath
of loyalty to trump and or disavow mitch
mcconnell publicly
and it will get really ugly really
quickly democrats should encourage this
and it is a beautiful thing
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 david p
here's a very interesting voicemail our
friend juan wrote in
and uh talked about his doctor
and he says his doctor has some very
particular beliefs but is a very good
doctor and what do i think about this
take a listen to this
hey david it's juan here so
the only doctor that in my opinion is
worth a dime
or
has helped me enough
to where
i feel better on a day-to-day basis
is basically
a doctor
who believes
that trump
will be
reinstated
okay
um this doctor
is a doctor that i have a lot of respect
for
a doctor that i'm willing to pay even
though i can afford without insurance
a doctor that if i come across
some lottery
i would even give him some of my lottery
uh
i find myself in a situation where
i have to go along with some of his
nonsense
because i fear that if i say something
that he doesn't like that i'll lose the
only doctor that has actually helped me
okay
can you believe that we've gotten to the
point
that we can't
even disagree without becoming
disagreeable or even losing a friendship
listen as i've said before
when people disagree about what the top
tax rate should be
it's not really the type of disagreement
that has a huge
material
impact on most relationships right if i
think hey we should have
uh the the top marginal tax rate should
go all the way up to 55 percent and you
believe we should have a flat tax of 18
percent they're like all right we just
disagree and it it's not viscerally
loaded in the same way that some of
these other things are on the complete
other end of the spectrum would be
beliefs like well
the jews should be killed right if you
find me a great doctor but the doctor
believes the jews should be killed it's
going to be hard for me to put that
aside and say listen i'm just coming in
here for you know this is my
ophthalmologist and not to pick on rand
paul um and that's it and then there's a
whole bunch of in-between stuff
for me
a doctor who is so delusional
that they believe trump is about to be
reinstated it's hard to imagine that
they are completely with it in every
other way
now there is this i've talked about this
condition before called paraphrenia
and paraphrenia is a mental disorder
where there's a very organized and
limited system of paranoid delusions
there's no hallucination
the intellect doesn't deteriorate the
personality doesn't deteriorate so
sometimes when when you're talking about
someone with paranoid delusions and or
schizophrenia
you talk to them and they seem like they
are not there in every sense like you
just say hey
you know what do you want for dinner
tonight and it's some unintelligible
rant and there's personality disorder
and there's a breakdown of their ability
to socialize and all these different
things
periphrenia is different in which
sometimes someone has a very it's almost
like a walled off delusional belief it
might be in this case trump's about to
be reinstated listen i i understand that
except the signs of climate change i
know how germ theory works
gravity i've got no problem with what is
a good and bad diet how to best raise a
kid we agree on everything but i have
this walled off delusion about trump is
secretly the president or he is about to
be reinstated or whatever
that's a condition called periphernian
that exists
it's just usually not something like the
president who lost is about to be
reinstated it's not that so as far as
advice to juan
you got to do whatever you got to do
but to me
it seems weird
that the only delusional belief would be
trump is imminently going to be
reinstated let me know what you think on
the bonus show today we are going to be
recapping the primary elections from
earlier this week we are going to talk
about a man who has tested positive for
monkey pox
covid
and hiv at the same time
it's an incredible situation and we will
also talk about dr anthony fauci step
stepping down in december after decades
of public service and republicans
claiming he's doing it to avoid
prosecution prosecution for what you
might ask well i don't have the answer
but we'll try to figure it out on the
bonus show sign up at joinpacman.com
to get instant access
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks
using my link below